GRADY POWELL: This is our
second chance tournament.
Tonight, the dueling begins.
And up first, the
Tough Breaks duel
where two competitors who
suffered catastrophic failures
return to the forge.
Name's James Mays.
I'm 41.
I was eliminated last time
because I was repairing work
and ended up breaking my blade.
[grunts]
Oh!
I knew it.
JAMES: I'm tremendously excited
to be in the second chance
tournament because it
gives me the opportunity
to prove to myself and
my family and friends
that I am worthy of being a
"Forged in Fire" champion.
My name's Steve Wells.
I'm 48 years old.
Last time I was here, my
blade broke because I missed
my normalization process
in the heat treat,
and I want to redeem that.
It's exhilarating being
back in the forge.
I guess I'm kind of
an adrenaline junkie.
And since I'm too old to ride
bulls, I guess this is my fix.
Gentlemen, welcome
to the forge.
You guys are here for
a chance to redeem
yourselves and go for that title
of "Forged in Fire" Champion.
But just because we're
giving you a second chance,
does not mean we're
going to go easy on you.
Today, we want you to
build blades out of these.
Bladesmiths, this is a pile
of blades that suffered
the same fate as yours.
They broke during testing and
they broke during a build.
We want you guys to
build signature blades
in your signature
style between 12
and 14 inches using at least
three pieces of this pile.
STEVE: What have I got to
deal with in these blades?
Something was wrong with
them in the beginning,
so I've got to find a
way to break them down
and put them into a new blade.
All right, gentlemen.
You have five
hours on the clock,
and your time starts now.
STEVE: Looks like the
table of J's broken blades
of his dreams.
JAMES: I've got one tang
with about 4 inches of blade,
another tang with
about an inch of blade,
and then a third piece that is
about six inches of just blade.
JUDGE: It really
looks like James
is going to try and do a stack.
JUDGE: There's just
so many variables
when you're stacking a
bunch of mystery metal
and trying to get a weld.
I've got my billet
welded together,
and I'm starting to draw it out.
Having a thin blade concerns
me a bit because you can break
a blade during
the testing stage,
and I would hate to see
that happen again today.
JUDGE: All right, James.
It's quenched.
[bleep]
I could see the
warping up from here.
I want to address that warp
before we get any further,
but I don't want to
snap my blade again.
GRADY POWELL: Don't
yank on it, man.
Oh yeah.
I feel like it's straight enough
that I can grind the rest down,
and I feel like everything's
going good at this point.
I get my handle traced, I run
it over to the tempering oven,
put it in there, and start
the tempering process
and go back to working
on my handle material.
I make my three-part
panel material,
and I've got it
setting in a curing.
It's time to go back
to work on my blade.
Oh, you gotta be
[bleep] kidding me.
JUDGE: Oh, he's got
a warp going on.
JAMES: I'm afraid to
start pulling and bending
on this one, so all I can
do is soften the spine
and straighten the blade.
I work on it the most I
can, and I get to a point
where I have to just go with it.
There's steel in there
I definitely don't want.
I see some really
bad delaminations,
so I got to make
another canister.
I can't see another
way to do it.
I'm a little worried
about getting
a weld good tight
fit inside that,
but I think I'll have
plenty of material.
I don't think it's going to
be a lack of material problem.
Well, that took a lot of time.
So while this
can's in the forge,
I'm going to do a
full-tang handle.
JUDGE: Oh, yeah.
Now, that-- that's hot.
JUDGE: Beautiful.
I'm feeling pretty
good about the can.
I think everything's good, so
I've got to quench this blade.
GRADY POWELL: All right.
We've got another quench.
Perfect.
Nice.
Looks good.
Everything's straight.
GRADY POWELL: Steve's got
his blade in his vise.
Looks like he's about
to torch temper.
STEVE: If I get too
much heat in this thing,
it's going to be too soft.
It's not going to hold an edge.
If I don't go enough, it's
going to be hard and brittle.
I'm spending my last few
minutes finishing my handle
and getting some
weight off my blade.
And I've still got to
get in the acid edge.
Too damn heavy.
GRADY POWELL: That's
something I haven't seen yet.
James is stropping
on his leather boots.
JAMES: I pull in a
little bit too much
and start shaving my boot.
If I'm fortunate enough
to win the competition,
I think I'll have the
money for new boots.
GRADY POWELL: 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Gentlemen, this round is over.
J: All right, James, Steve,
welcome to our Tough Breaks
strength test, the antler chop.
Now, I'm gonna take your blades
and beat them mercilessly
on these antlers
to test your edge
retention as well as the overall
construction of your blades.
Now, what your blades
do to the antlers
is second to what the
antlers to to your blades.
Both you guys had blades
break last time you were here,
and let's hope that
doesn't happen again.
James, are you ready?
Let's do it.
OK.
Let's go for it.
I hope J don't
snap my blade again.
[music playing]
[grunting]
[sighs] [bleep], man.
All right, James.
You survived.
Good job.
You took broken blades and
made it into something that
can survive an antler chop.
I'll start off with your handle.
You do have the
contouring there.
That helps a lot,
but it feels like it
tapers down towards the back.
You do have a slight
kick to the left now,
and you've got some chipping,
but it didn't break.
Good job.
Thank you.
Hey, Steve.
You ready to do this?
Does it matter?
No.
We're going to do it anyway.
[music playing]
[grunting]
All right, Steve.
You survived.
Great job.
Everything's tight
and nothing moved,
but you do have a
bunch of chipping
and rolling right here.
Your handle's very blocky.
Rounding these corners off would
have made it more comfortable.
And the other thing
is there's just
a lot of weight on this
thing, but everything
else is right and tight.
Good job.
Thank you.
All right, bladesmiths.
Your blades made
out of broken blades
survived a very brutal
test by a judge who's
notorious for breaking blades.
But we need to find out
how sharp your blades are.
This is a sharpness test,
the pork loin slice.
To find out how sharp
your weapons are,
I'm going to take your
weapons to try to cut
through these pork loins.
James, you're up first.
Are you ready for this?
- Let's go.
- All right.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, James.
Let's talk about your blade.
First up, there's a
nice balance to it.
It's easy to wield.
Your handle construction
is on the smooth side,
but cutting through these pork
loins was not hard at all.
Your weapon, sir, it will cut.
Thank you.
All right, Steve, your turn.
So you're ready?
- Yes, sir.
- Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, Steve.
Let's talk about
your blade here.
First up, it's a heavy
blade that you got here.
But your edge here, sir,
easy to cut and wield.
Overall, sir, it will cut.
Thank you, sir.
GRADY POWELL: Well, gentlemen,
you both broke the curse
with your boneyard blades,
but only one of you guys
can move forward in the next
round of this tournament.
And the bladesmith
leaving the forage is--
Steve.
Unfortunately, your blade just
didn't make the cut today.
I'm going to have to ask you
to step off the forge floor.
Thanks for having me, guys.
Good job, buddy.
Nice to see you again, Steve.
Thanks.
STEVE: I left my
blade too heavy.
You know, I was erring
on the side of caution,
making it good and stout,
and I just overdid it.
I just want people to know that
this is a tough competition.
And if you think it's
not, come and try.
GRADY POWELL: Well, James,
you know what that means.
You have won your duel.
You're going to be
receiving a check for $2,000
and you've got yourself a
slot in the final round of
our second chance tournament.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
GRADY POWELL: Very
well done, man.
JAMES: Thank you.
Woo!
I am just in utter astonishment.
I cannot believe what happened.
To make it all the way
is just unbelievable.
Steve was such an
awesome competitor.
I know that this
is not over yet.
I know there's three other
smiths there that have just
as much want and drive and
desire to be "Forged in Fire"
champions as me, so I've
got a long road ahead.